hello hi how's it goin I finally got it
I got the 10 million subscriber ply I
think it's pretty much just because
Felix made a big stink about his but I
got it as collateral damage is just as
good as anything about giving it out of
pure merit but it's really cool and it's
really heavy and this probably shouldn't
amend the first thought when I got it
but I I imagined how easy it would be to
beat someone to death with it which
probably reveal something very bad about
my personality but I got it it's so cool
I know I shouldn't say that cliche so
much but it's really really awesome and
I only have you guys to thank for it and
I actually don't know what I'm gonna do
with it because I'm not one for awards
I'm not one for collectables I'm not one
for uh keepsakes and stuff like that but
this is special because it represents
like how far we have come as a community
and it represents you know how much we
have accomplished and I think as
testament to how much I appreciate this
award I'm going to be walking around the
entirety of VidCon with this in my arms
much like when I got the taco trophy
that was given to me by rich I'm gonna
go get it yeah but much like this taco
trophy that has been by my bedside since
I got it
some of you have noticed it in the
background of my videos uh yeah keep it
by my bed because I'm so proud of what
I've done to win this taco trophy and
this is just as cool maybe even cooler I
don't know they're kind of 50/50 on the
coolness scale but I'm going to be
carrying this around with me at VidCon
which is just in a few days also
jacksepticeye is currently in town and
we're going to be doing a lot of cool
stuff follow us on social media so you
can see all the stupid pictures that
we're going to take and stuff so we're
all going to be at VidCon of going to be
having a great time and I don't want you
guys to worry because this year there's
going to be a much higher security while
we're there obviously in relation to
what we talked about in the last vlog
but I don't want you guys to worry at
all we're still going to meet
everything's still going to be fun we're
going to be there like we mean Jack you
know all my friends we go there to meet
you guys and we don't want anything to
get in the way of that and things might
be a little bit different this year but
that doesn't mean that we're going to
meet any less
yes I go there not to network not to
socialize not to hang out not to go to
parties I go there to meet you guys and
I'm going to be carrying this around
with me I just won't be able to go on
the public floor with it so look for me
if you find me say hi but I don't know
if I'll be able to go around and just
walk around wherever I want but it's
still going to be a good time and then
after that next month I am going to
comic-con which should be if you met me
last year at comic-con you noticed that
it was a little bit crazy there were a
lot of people and then comic-con got
angry because we were blocking up the
hallways actually the Marvel booth got
angry because we were blocking up their
like their big whatever the heck they
were advertising but it should be a lot
better organized this year we're gonna
be selling posters that I'll gladly sign
for you guys and if you don't know these
are the poster covers their varying
things and if you didn't know these are
actually the cover art for the upcoming
markiplier comic which is still
available I think I think if you order
in the next like week you can still get
the July version but they're coming out
like July August whatever the next month
is don't question my ability to count
months I know what month come after
August do that man so you can still get
them in there an exclusive foil cover
version of it and then after this
initial run you'll be able to get it
later but it just won't be the foil
cover so if you want that check the link
in the description below you can still
get it so yeah so in other news while
Jack is in town we should be making a
lot of collaborative videos and also
we're going to be working on the ninja
sex party shoot and also at the end of
this week nine four of the five nights
at Freddy's musical with random
encounters will be coming out I'll let
you guys know about that but just keep
an eye on it I think it's going to be on
their Channel on Friday I'll put links
in Facebook and Twitter and wherever I
can to get to it but thank you guys so
much for supporting that effort and
thank you guys so much for supporting us
in making videos I think Jack might have
gotten this also so I don't know if he
brought it with him VidCon but if he did
I'm gonna talk him into both of us
carrying this around so proud and if he
doesn't have it then I'm going to carry
it around and gloat about how much
better I am than him because I also have
a taco trophy so thank you guys so much
for watching I can't wait to be you guys
in VidCon I can't wait to meet you guys
at Comic Con it's gonna be a lot of fun
and we're going to do some cool stuff
while we're there so thank you again
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
i can'twe bye bye interval